you ever have an older relative who told
you old family stories yes like that so
folks this is a patron sponsor of review
and this is a film that I had a very
vague awareness of I think insofar as
like I remember seeing trailers for it
like in the now available on home video
segments in front of stuff that like I
rented from the video store because I'm
old and I grew up with video stores so
this is the secret of Rowan inish now I
wasn't really sure what to expect going
in I knew it was a movie from John
Sayles and if you don't know who John
Sayles is he's actually kind of an
interesting figure all things considered
because basically he pays his bills as a
script doctor and a screenwriter for
hire for trash the demand writes a lot
of not great films or punches up a lot
of scripts for not great films but
that's what pays his bills and then it
allows him the ability to make small
offbeat personal probably not gonna make
their money back little film projects
that he directs this being one of those
now I'd only seen two John Sayles movies
prior to this so going in the guy had
about a 50-50 split with me cuz I had
seen Lone Star which I didn't really
like and eight men out which I liked
quite a bit but neither of which I'd
seen anytime recently so this was an
interesting one to to look into now in
the trying to sum up the story is very
difficult because it's not really a
story in much of the traditional sense
there is stuff that happens there is a
narrative framework to it
that's not really the point I don't want
to over stress this this isn't like
trying to be a lyrical film like
something from Terrence Malick or
anything like that
it's evoking something very specific so
this is set in Ireland I don't know what
year it's set in but it's like early
1900s is the vibe I got and it deals
primarily with a young girl named Fiona
who's comes from a family say family her
immediate family her father siblings
mother they lived in a city having moved
there after sort of the traditional
family home the island of roan inish was
abandoned for reasons that get explained
as the movie goes on and at the start of
the movie it opens with Fiona's mother's
funeral and her father sort of accepting
that he's not really in a position to
raise this kid her other siblings are
older it can kind of take care of
themselves sends her off to live with
her grandparents who live on the coast
within sight of Rouen inish but they
they don't live on the island anymore
and there are things that sort of
happened with her that she learns and
hears about and that's kind of the thing
what what this film goes to evoke is
capturing the sense of oral history that
was kind of the main way that family
history was shared in that part of the
world traditionally now I don't know a
ton about Irish folklore and things of
that nature I know a little bit and what
little I know I've always found
fascinating there's something that I had
heard about recently that apparently the
the like the national libraries in
Ireland had like tasked young people in
remote villages to basically find the
oldest living person they could and ask
that person to tell them family and
fairy stories and record them because
all of these stories and all these
traditions
completely oral they're not written down
so that's very much how knowledge and
folklore is passed on or or
traditionally has been and this film
captures that whole feel she gets
stories told to her by her grandfather
by a cousin of hers by her grandmother
and some of them overlap with each other
some of them contradict each other some
of them might have a basis in reality
some might be completely made up but
that's the feel of the thing overall and
as he said there is a narrative and
there is sort of a ultimately there is a
goal that Fiona develops that I can't
really say what it is without getting
into spoilers but I don't think I'm
going to talk spoilers on this film
because it's it's little-known enough
that I kind of wanted if what I'm
talking about sounds interesting I would
recommend you go and see it which I
suppose brings me to the point that I
did actually quite enjoy this this is
definitely different from a lot of what
I take in in terms of my own choices for
entertainment and certainly much
different than the vast majority of what
I talk about on this channel it's the
kind of film that honestly folks kind of
have to pay me to watch and that sounds
bad but I don't mean like yeah I'd never
watch that I just mean like and I point
this out if you give me the option for
like a little offbeat
indie family kind of thing or something
with lasers and rockets or wizards or
what-have-you I'm usually gonna go for
that just cuz that's where my natural
pull is doesn't mean I won't like what's
over here
it just means you kind of have to push
me to get to it so the way I tend to
experience films like this oh man I do
often enjoy them but I you know I have
to have a friend who like really pushes
me to watch it with them or in the case
like this be commissioned to review it
and I I have a feeling that the that the
patronize er who commissioned me to
review this has kind of been paying
attention because something that I've
said more than a few times that I must
suck
for his stories about stories about the
power of stories about how they bring us
together about how they bond us about
how we use them to pass on knowledge and
that is a very big part of this film
since it is capturing that oral
tradition of sort of rural Ireland it is
very much steeped in this notion that
stories have meaning and power whether
or not their true isn't even the point
though if they are or if elements of
them are maybe that's a bonus but that
there is power and there's value simply
in the story and in the telling of the
story of the passing on of it and there
is something to be gained something to
be learned from that whether it is
something that you learn about the place
in which you live about the family that
you come from but there's something
there that you can take from it and that
there is power and strength and unity
even in stories and storytelling and
like I said I have a big sucker for that
I love stories about stories especially
when they're done well because at their
worst those kinds of things can end up
being pretentious and can end up being
like you know authors kind of patting
themselves on the back be like yes we
storytellers are awesome and that's how
you get lady in the water which honestly
I'm also softer on that most people are
but still acknowledge self-indulgent as
heck but here it's because it feels so
authentic to the time period and the
type of life that is trying to evoke it
never comes across as pretentious also
loved the music in this I I really like
traditional Irish and also Scottish
music I love the pipes I love things
like that and and the music is very much
evocative of that so that was really
nice for me to experience as well
overall the the whole thing
it just gave me a very nice feeling it's
I was classy it's not the deepest thing
in the world it does have depth to it
but it's it doesn't have a core message
at least not that I picked up it's not
trying to drive home a specific point
it's just seeking to kind of immerse you
in this way of interacting of this way
of sharing your history and your beliefs
and what's important to you with other
people or having them share it with you
if I was gonna make any criticism the
one thing I would say is there are times
in which the dialogue comes across as a
bit stiff and a bit stilted I don't know
if it's actually fair to criticize that
though because I honestly don't know
whether or not that is accurate to the
the kind the ways of talking of these
kinds of people at the time period in
which it's set I don't know it it may be
authentic for them to be talking the way
that they are it may not regardless
either way it does come across as a
little stilted and a little stiff
sometimes if I were to sort of know
prise it I would say maybe chalk that up
to the fact that certainly the older
characters like the grandparents you
know English maybe not a second language
but it's not their only language you
know they will also speak Celtic or
traditional Irish not that they do very
much in this film because they cuz they
that was very early on that Fiona
doesn't so they don't speak to her with
that but it's very clear that they know
that so I guess I can kind of chalk it
up to that the film just left me feeling
very nice and I'm actually gonna make a
comparison which is maybe weird but I'm
just gonna do it anyway is also probably
pretty unique to me but for some reason
this just stuck in my head as the film
was kind of wrapping up there's there's
a podcaster that I listened to a
gentleman by the name of Andrew Leyland
he has a number of podcast projects but
the his
personal one the one that like he does
whatever he wants and it's only him it's
called the palace of glittering delights
and he ends each episode by saying
everything's gonna be alright and I've
been there's something whenever I hear
him say that
it just gives me a very yeah okay
feeling and I got that same feeling from
this film so that was I was just really
nice plus you know the the setting is
gorgeous it's not shot in a particularly
showy way like with with a more budget
I'm sure it could have been shot in a
way to really show off the landscape but
it's its shot very matter-of-factly but
it's still a gorgeous landscape lots of
seals in it and and it's it is a very
nice film you do have to be prepared to
get around an authentic Irish accent
though so if you're not used to hearing
that it might take you a little while to
sort of queue into the dialogue but I
enjoyed this and if you like offbeat
stories or if you're like me you're a
sucker for stories about stories or you
want to just try something a little less
straightforward if you can find this I
do recommend it that's actually the
trick I couldn't at least not on any of
the services I subscribe to I couldn't
find it streaming I couldn't even find
it for rental like digital rental on
Amazon I ended up having to get a
secondhand copy but if you can manage to
get your like I'm not gonna say like
because I'm sure getting it like brand
new mint and the box is like crazy
expensive but if you can happen to come
across it and if anything that I've said
sounds interesting to you it's
absolutely worth watching I'm glad I saw
it and now own it actually so yeah
that's the secret of roan inish an
unusual
for me to talk about but I kind of like
that I am able to do that so what are
your thoughts on the SIL have you ever
heard of it have you seen it do you know
John Sayles other work however you wish
to participate in this a favorite film
based off of Celtic lore that'd work if
you wanted an animated companion to this
song of the sea' works very well so
whatever your thoughts are on anything
vaguely related to anything I've just
said drop something down the comments
let's talk about it there's a bunch of
stuff down there to do as well
there's the patient which as I said was
how this review is sponsored but there
are plenty of other tiers of support
plus there's my socials down there PL
box go check them out or you also don't
have to I appreciate all the support I
get but I'm not gonna tell you what to
do because at the end of the day you're
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]